this bitter  [Music]  my fellow citizens of the world  what i have to say to you  is not something i was ever prepared to  say many of you know by now we are  suffering from inexplicable and  seemingly unrelated incidents  [Music]  ranging from power outages  to the destruction of infrastructure and  homes  [Music]  we now believe these incidents are not  unrelated  but in fact  connected what is being visited upon our  earth contact  is not of our earth  [Applause]  listen to me  [Music]  was that your only encounter  is  [Music]  we might be all that stands between life  as we know it and the end of our  existence  the world wants to test us  to see if it can break us  not today  [Music]  bitter after  [Music]  you